thank you
[Music]
the only true wisdom is in knowing you
know nothing
the unexamined life is not worth living
there is only one good knowledge and one
evil ignorance
[Music]
I cannot teach anybody anything I can
only make them think
wonder is the beginning of wisdom
be kind for everyone you meet is
fighting a hard battle
strong Minds discuss ideas average Minds
discuss events weak Minds discuss people
to find yourself think for yourself
education is the kindling of a flame not
the filling of a vessel
by all means Mary if you get a good wife
you'll become happy
if you get a bad one you'll become a
philosopher
be slow to fall into friendship
but when you are in continue firm and
constant
he who is not content with what he has
would not be content with what he would
like to have
children today love luxury they have Bad
Manners contempt for authority they show
disrespect for elders and loved chatter
in place of exercise
sometimes you put walls up not to keep
people out but to see who cares enough
to break them down
know thyself
foreign
[Music]
let him who would move the world first
move himself
when the debate is lost slander becomes
the tool of the loser
death may be the greatest of all human
blessings
the only good is knowledge the only evil
is ignorance
contentment is natural wealth luxury is
artificial poverty
do not do to others what angers you if
done to you by others
every action has its pleasures and its
price
employ your time in improving yourself
by other men's writings so that you
shall come easily by what others have
labored hard for
no man has the right to be an amateur in
the matter of physical training
it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty and strength
of which his body is capable
I am not an Athenian or a Greek but a
citizen of the world
preferred knowledge to wealth for the
one is transitory the other perpetual
the hour of departure has arrived and we
go our separate ways I to die and you to
live which of these two is better only
God knows
we cannot live better than in seeking to
become better
understanding a question is half the
answer
Envy is the ulcer of the Soul
[Music]
beware the barrenness of a busy life
the hottest love has the coldest end
[Music]
I know that I am intelligent because I
know that I know nothing
[Music]
yes you wished seem
from the deepest desires often comes the
deadliest hate
be nicer than necessary to everyone you
meet everyone is fighting some kind of
battle
thou shouldest Eat to Live not live to
eat
the greatest way to live with honor in
this world is to be what we pretend to
be
if you want to be a good Saddler saddle
the worst horse for if you can tame that
one you can tame them all
true wisdom comes to each of us when we
realize how little we understand about
life ourselves and the world around us
once made equal to man woman becomes his
Superior
I pray thee o God that I may be
beautiful Within
[Music]
the really important thing is not to
live but to live well
and to live well means along with more
enjoyable things in life to live
according to your principles
one should never do wrong in return nor
mistreat any man no matter how one has
been mistreated by him
life contains but two tragedies one is
not to get your heart's desire the other
is to get it
the easiest and noblest way is not to be
crushing others but to be improving
yourself
[Music]
if all our misfortunes were laid in one
common Heap once everyone must take an
equal portion most people would be
content to take their own and depart
the beginning of wisdom is the
definition of terms
he is richest who is content with the
least for content is the wealth of
nature
[Music]
in all of us even in Good Men there is a
lawless wild beast nature which peers
out in sleep
[Music]
my friend care for your psyche know
yourself for once we know ourselves we
may learn how to care for ourselves
[Music]
children nowadays are tyrants they
contradict their parents gobble their
food and tyrannize their teachers
the greatest blessings granted to
mankind come by way of Madness which is
a Divine gift
what screws us up the most in life is
the picture in our head of what it's
supposed to be
of good cheer about death and know this
of a truth that no evil can happen to a
good man either in Life or after death
think not those faithful who praise all
thy words and actions
but those who kindly reprove thy faults
I only know that I know nothing
all men's souls are Immortal but the
souls of the righteous are Immortal and
divine
virtue does not come from wealth but
wealth and every other good thing which
men have comes from virtue
through your Rags I see your vanity
the highest Realms of thought are
impossible to reach without first
detaining an understanding of compassion
to move the world we must move ourselves
he who is unable to live in society or
he who has no need because he is
sufficient for himself
must either be a beast or a god
[Music]
not life but good life is to be chiefly
valued
wisdom begins in wonder
I know you won't believe me but the
highest form of Human Excellence is to
question oneself and others
[Music]
the mind is everything what you think
you become
there is no solution seek it lovingly
the misuse of language induces evil in
the soul
living well and beautifully and justly
are all one thing
when you want wisdom and insight as
badly as you want to breathe it is then
you shall have it
there is no greater evil one can suffer
than to hate reasonable discourse
to express oneself badly is not only
faulty as far as language goes but does
harm to the soul
those who are hardest to love need love
the most
give me Beauty in my inward soul may the
outward and the inward man be one
it is better to change an opinion than
to persist in a wrong one
is it true is it kind is it necessary
he is not only Idol who does nothing but
he is Idol who might be better employed
be true to thine own self
foreign
and the outward man be as one
you're not ashamed of caring so much for
the making of money and for fame and
Prestige when you neither think nor care
about wisdom and truth and the
Improvement of your soul
to know thyself is the beginning of
wisdom
as the marriage or celibacy let a man
take which course he will he will be
sure to repent
a system of morality which is based on
relative emotional values is a mere
illusion a thoroughly vulgar conception
which has nothing sound in it and
nothing true
[Music]
beauty is a short-lived tyranny
wealth does not bring goodness but
goodness brings wealth in every other
blessing both to the individual and to
the state
my plainness of speech makes them hate
me and what is their hatred but a proof
that I am speaking the truth
true knowledge exists in knowing that
you know nothing
such as thy words are such will thy
affections be esteemed
and such will thy Deeds be as thy
affections and such thy life as thy
Deeds thank you
[Music]
an unconsidered life is not worth living
how many things can I do without
the only thing I know is that I know
nothing
trust not a woman when she weeps for it
is her nature to weep when she wants her
will
as for me all I know is that I know
nothing for when I don't know what
Justice is I hardly know whether it is a
kind of virtue or not or whether a
person who has it is happy or unhappy
now the hour depart has come
I go to die you go to live which of us
goes to the better lot is known to No
One except to God
wisdom is knowing you know nothing
one thing only I know and that is that I
know nothing